Und ja, mein Prüfung ist am Ende dieses Monats.
Okay.
Und sind Sie Facharztin oder?
Nein, ich habe noch nie gearbeitet.
Okay, alles klar.
Direkt nach dem Abschluss habe ich hiergekommen.
Okay, verstanden, alles klar.
Gut, dann fangen wir an.
Okay, ich mache erstes Mal, habe ich ein bisschen Angst, aber ja.
Ja, okay.
Danke schön.
Okay, ich fange an.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Bayrak.
Ich bin auf diese Station als Estanerstin tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bitte unterbrücken Sie mich, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder waren zu Fragen haben.
Bevor Sie mir Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, ich würde gerne ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Müller.
Martin Müller.
Martin Müller, ja.
Herr Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
42?
Mhm, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1. Januar 1982.
1. Januar 1982.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ein Mitte 72 groß.
72?
Und wie schwer sind Sie?
75 kg.
Ja, Herr Müller.
Was fühlt es dir so aus?
Wie kann Ihnen helfen?
Ja, also ich habe seit ungefähr jetzt 24 Stunden schon seit gestern, habe ich Übelkeit erbrechen und auch ein bisschen durchverlehrlich gesagt.
Mhm, ja.
Haben Sie früher eine Beschwerden gehabt oder ist das erst einmal befroßen?
Ich habe das schon mal ein paar Mal gehabt, aber das war in meiner Kindheit.
So schlimm habe ich das noch nie gehabt.
Okay, es war Kindheit.
Überlehrkeit erbrechen und Durchfall.
Ja, wie viele Mal haben Sie erbrochen?
Ja, drei Mal habe ich unterbrochen seit gestern.
Mhm, drei Mal.
Wie sagt die Abrochene aus? War es Blut oder normal?
Nein, das war gar nicht, was ich gegessen habe.
Normal, mage, inhalt.
Und Durchfall, wie oft haben Sie das gemacht?
Bestimmt schon seit gestern, jetzt ungefähr 15, 16 Mal.
15 Mal. Ja.
Wie war die Konsistenz und Farbe von Stur?
Wie Wasser.
Wie Wasser?
Haben Sie Blut gesehen?
Mhm.
Ja, verstehe.
Und haben Sie Schmerzen am Bauch?
Ich habe Kräfte, ja. Ich habe richtige Panpartike Schmerzen.
Mhm, ja.
Ja, okay.
Und wo sind diese genau Schmerzen? Ganz im Bauch oder bestimmte Mitte?
Eigentlich im ganzen Bauch, aber eher so mittig, in der Mitte.
Ganz im Bauch Mitte.
Ja.
Ist diese Beschwerden plötzlich angefangen, sind diese Beschwerden oder langsam?
Ganz plötzlich.
Ja, okay.
Mitte.
Und was haben Sie gegessen vor diese Beschwerden angefangen?
Haben Sie bestimmte Sache gemacht oder?
Nein, ich war auf einer Feier gewesen, also bei der Geburtstagsfeier
und bearbeitet gegessen.
Geburtstagfeier.
Haben Sie eine ungewöhnliche Essen gegessen?
Nein, wir haben Fleisch gegessen und wir haben Kuchen gegessen.
Fleisch und Kuchen, ja.
Ja, verstehe.
War das Pumichgeschmack oder?
Eigentlich nicht.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie gereist in letzter Zeit, zum Beispiel in letzter Woche oder?
Was hab ich?
Haben Sie gereist in letzter Woche?
Ich bin gereist.
Geist.
Ob ich im Austand war?
Ja, oder ja, Ausland oder eine andere Platte haben Sie gereist.
Reist.
Ob ich gereist bin, also weggehend, im Austand gewesen, wenn ich gereist bin?
Ja, gereist.
Ja, nein, ich war in Deutschland.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie viel Bauch?
Ein bisschen, ja.
Haben Sie es gemessen?
Ja, ich habe gemessen, das war 28,2.
38,2.
38,2, ja.
Füllen Sie sich immer fühlt sich oder?
Nein.
Okay, ja, okay.
Okay.
Ja, ich habe das auch gemessen, Sie sagt mir ganz im Bauch, aber besonders im Mitte.
Ganz genau, im Mitte, da im Bauchnabern.
Ja, okay.
Okay, Herr Müller.
Jetzt, ich würde gerne Ihnen ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Okay.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Haben Sie Schweißausbrühe?
Ja, manchmal schon.
In diesen 24 Stunden, ja?
Seit gestern?
Ja.
Okay.
Okay, und?
Haben Sie Schütteilfrost?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihre Impfstatus?
Ich glaube, die ist aktuell.
Okay.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit Kilo abgenommen, das Wasser genommen?
Ja, gestern bestimmt.
Ob ich in der Tat war.
Ja, können Sie Essen oder trinken?
Ja, aber ich breche das zu Potheira.
Und da tu ich viel.
Ja, verstehe.
Okay.
Also jetzt, Sie haben Appetitlosigkeit wegen des Öbelkaltes?
Nein, ich habe keine Appetitlosigkeit, ich kann nur nicht Essen.
Aber?
Ja, verstehe.
Ja, okay.
Okay, jetzt, Sie kommen in Ihre Vorgeschichte.
Habt ihr Sie manche wichtige Vorerkrankungen von den,
die ich wissen sollte?
Zum Beispiel, Zuckerkrankheit oder Brutoftdruck,
Ne, ich habe eine Schwerin, ich habe nur eine Reflex.
Ja.
Nehmen Sie Dagege, Nein?
Magneson, ich meine.
Magneson.
Magneson, wie ist diese Medikamente,
oder ist
ohne Pratsche
nur einmal täglich richtig
ja auch nicht immer
wenn es sehr stark ist, dann nehme ich die einen
ja verstehe nicht immer
kennst du die Dosierung?
sonst wenigung
dann ist das nicht so
ja ok
und nehmst du eine andere Medikamente ein
Regalmester oder Beiberdars
ja wenn ich Kopfschmerznahme lebe
ich über Profene oder so
sonst nichts
600 Milligramm oder?
ja ok
ja
haben sie Allergie gegen bestimmte Medikamente
oder bestimmte Nachungsmaterial
nein
haben sie Unfallzregeligkeit
gegen zum Beispiel Fruchtose, Laktose oder
nein
Leben, jetzt bekommen wir ihre Familiengeschichte
Leben, ihre Alternative
ja
und leiden ihre Alternative
an wichtige
mancher Vorerkrankungen
ja die haben beide Blutotrug
und meine Mutter
hat noch nicht Schilddrüden unter Funktion
und mein Vater
hat eine Vorstattakation
ist das behandelt würde oder?
das wird behandelt ja
ok
ja haben sie Geschwister
ich bin ein Kind
ein Kind
haben sie schon mal Operation gehabt?
nein, noch nie
ok
jetzt bekommen wir ihre
Gewohnheiten
rauen sie oder haben sie schon gelacht?
ich rau keine Haare
wie viel Zigaretten rauen sie täglich?
halbe Schachtel
ja sagt man rauen sie
ich habe schon mit 18 Jahren angefangen
18 Jahre
18 Jahre angefangen
genau
ja
ok
und trinken sie Alkohol?
ja
woanders
was trinken sie?
kommt immer noch an Cocktails
Bier
das was da ist
ja
Glas oder Flasche?
wie viel?
unterschiedlich
ja ok
ja, bitte nehmen sie die nächste Frage nicht versuchen
das ist eine Routine Frage
nehmen sie Drogen ein oder haben sie schon kontaktiert?
Kanabis
nehmen sie ein oder
nur einmal probieren?
ja, nimm ich ein
nimm sie, wie oft?
am Wochenende meistens
meistens wocheneinander
und was haben sie gesagt?
am meistens am wocheneinander
am meistens
ja ok
und was sind sie von Büro?
Büro kauf man
haben sie Stress beim Arbeit?
ja
jeder ne
ich kann nicht vorstellen
und sind sie fehlert?
ich bin allein lebend
allein lebend
haben sie Partner oder
haben sie Partnerin?
ja
und haben sie Kinder?
nein
ja, haben sie Stress
im Sozialleben?
eigentlich nicht
ja
diese Geburtstagfeier
waren sie gestern
oder wann waren sie diese Feier?
vor 3 Tagen
ja, Herr Müller
das hat alles gestern angefallen?
aber die Geburt zu zweier feier
waren vor 3 Tagen
das war heute Sonntag
das war am Donnerstag
mehr am Frühstück
mehr am Freitag
zuhörbar
ok
Freitag
Herr Müller, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen
jetzt ich mache eine kurze Zusammenfassung
wir haben
seit gestern
überkalt
sie haben
Englische Beschwerden
in letzter Zeit noch nie gehabt
nur es war am Kindheit
und sie haben 3 Mal Albrochen
wie normal magen
und hatten Essenrechte
und sie haben ungefähr 15 Mal
durch Fall gehabt
und es war wie Wasser
und sie haben Teambulut gesehen
und sie haben auch
Bachschmerzen
Es wie wie Krämpfe
und diese Schmerzen im ganzen Bauch
besonders im Mitte
und sie waren
vor 3 Tagen
in einer Geburtstagfeier
und sie haben hier Fleisch
und Zuchen gegessen
und sie haben in letztes Mal
nicht ausgetragen
und jetzt
sie haben Fieber
und es war 38,2 Grad
und außerdem
sie haben Schweißausbrühe
und
ihre Appetit ist normal
aber wenn sie Essen oder Trinken
danach machen sie wieder
müssen sie wieder erbrechen
und
sie haben keine
Vererkrankungen außerdem reflekt
sie nehmen manchmal
eine Paktur
und
sie rachen
halbeschachter
seit ihrer 18. Leber
und sie trinken manchmal Alkohol
sie nehmen manchmal
Brocken und wohernehmende besonders
und sie sind Bürokaufmob
und sie haben eine
eine Paktur
und sie wollen alleine
haben Sie Fragen?
Nein, ich würde gerne,
was es ist und ich würde gerne
etwas helfen
Ja, natürlich
Was habe ich denn jetzt?
Ja, Herr Müller
Nein,
denken Sie nicht so schlimm
jetzt wir haben nur
an einem Nesegespräch durchgeführt
und
ich würde gerne
Körper hier untersuchen
danach ich werde für Stabobulut ab
und
sobald
die Ergebnisse ich bekomme
werde ich wieder bei Ihnen und
werden wir Ihre Situation besprechen
Okay
Und von gern
Für Astrophisprä
Ja, genau
Brauchen Sie
seid oder
möchten Sie weiter machen?
Okay
2 Minuten
Okay, schneller
Ja, besser wenn Sie bitte
nehmen Sie seid
Okay, danke
Hat jemand
Welche
Fragen
eine Frage
Sie möchten?
Ja, bitte
Herr Müller, haben Sie
eine Konzentrationsstörung oder
Bewusstseinsveränderung seit gestern?
Nein, aber ich bin total schwach
auf den Beinen
Also ich kann kaum stehen, mir geht es
überhaupt nicht gut
Ist Wasserlöster verwendet oder gar nicht?
Nein
Okay
Und
Ab der
Teilnehmer der Partie
einige
Teilnehmer diese gleiche beschwarten
Nur Sie
Ja, tatsächlich, meine Freundin hat das auch
und meine Freunde haben das auch
Okay, okay, dann
Eine Frage
Sag ich, ob er
heute habe ich einen neuen Patient
aufgenommen
Ich würde gerne von meinem Patient
vorstellen
Darf ich, haben Sie Zeit?
Könntest du mich warten?
Ich geh mal zu
Danke
Martin Müller
Er ist 42 Jahre alt
Erste, erste, 82
Geboren
Und 1,72 Meter
Und 75 Kilogramm
Er hatte
sich heute seit gestern
Seit gestern
Nausea
Seit gestern angefangen
Emesis und Diare
Er berichtete
dass die einige Beschwarten
in letzter Zeit
Er
nicht
Er hatte nicht
Er hatte noch
Er
Er hatte 3
Mal
Er hatte 3 Mal
Er hat 3 Mal
Er hatte
15 Mal Diare
Beide
war
ohne
Blutung
Er berichtete
auch noch, er habe
Bauchschmerzen
im ganzen Bauch
Polikartik
Und
unser Patient berichtete
Vor 3 Tagen
Er war im Feier
Er habe Fleisch
und Puchen gegessen
Er hatte seine Freundin
Er hatte älhe Beschwerden
Er hatte die Fragen
nach Reise ins Ausland
Die Syrerie
die Stomni
Schüttefrost und Inapetanz
wurden verneint
Er hatte die Fragen nach Reise ins Ausland
Die Syrerie, die Stomni
Leider
Er an Noah Reff
Krankheit
dagegen nehmt er um den Pazol
20 Milligramm
bei Bedarf
und
die Medikamente
außerdem diese Medikamente
Nehmt er ein
bei Bedarf
in Profen 400 Milligramm
Nehmt er in Profen 400 Milligramm
bei Bedarf ein
Allergien
bei ihm nicht bekannt
äh
Die Familiennamenase
er gab atariere Hypertonie
und
Benenfrostata Hyperplase
bei Vater
Atariere Hypertonie
und Hypotroide
Hypotroide
bei der Mutter
äh er
noch nie Operation gehabt
und äh er sei rauha
und äh er rauha
äh
zwölf
pack er die
die rauha
er rauha seit dem
18. Lebensjahr
halbeschachteltäglich
äh das bedeutet
äh die Nikotin Konzum
ist zwölf Packiers
er trinke gelegenlich
Alkohol
äh äh er nehme
gelegenlich
besonders an wohernende Druck
ein und er sei
Bürokaufmann
von Beruf
Cannabis
äh er sei
Bürokaufmann von Beruf
er habe Stress beim Arbeid
und äh
er wohne alleine
äh habe er
Partnerin
keine Kinder
ja das war
ok sehr gut
ähm wie gehts sie
ist er
oder ist er schwach auf den Beinen
ja äh
oder er trinken oder kann er nicht trinken
äh er sagte äh
er fühle sich
äh schwach
und äh er habe keine Appetitlosigkeit
er kann essen und trinken
äh aber
äh essen oder trinken
muss er wieder äh äh äh
äh erbrochen
er brechen
oder hat sofort durchfallen
ja
wie was glauben sie denn was er hat
ich denke er hat ähm
Gastroenteritis
ähm ähm
wegen diese Fleisch oder
Kuchen
ähm ähm im Palze habe er gewesen
ja ähm ähm
als differential Diagnosen
äh ja mein VdA Diagnoses
äh Gastroenteritis
als differential Diagnosen
kommen ähm
kommen
ein äh nur
nur Enteritis
oder ein Pankreatitis
in Detra
ok was ist mit
chronisch
entzündlichen Damerkrankungen
Morbus Kron, Folgeres Ulzer Rosa
ja ähm natürlich
wegen dieser 15 mal
Durchfall habe ich gleich
er gedacht aber diese Beschwerden
ist sehr akut nur
gestern, seit gestern
habe ich, habe er
die Beschwerden und äh
wenn er früher ähnliche Beschwerden
gehabt habe ähm denken
ja können wir denken
diese Kronische Damerkrankungen
ja so, was machen sie mit dem Palzen jetzt
jetzt erstmal
ich würde gerne Körperlechontosophon machen
besonders äh im Bau
und wegen dieser Durchfall
äh er habe
wahrscheinlich die Plistik
äh
Verlust
und äh ich muss gucken
Digitonus der
Haut
ähm erst mal
ich würde gerne kontrollieren
habe er ähm
Plistikkeit
und ähm
also ja
äh dann erst mal
danach mache ich
Blutabnahme äh besonders
äh äh Entzündungsparameter
Therapie
und äh Prokastonen
äh erst mal Therapie ist genug ja
äh ich kann, ich kann
diese Parameter kontrollieren und
äh ich wegen dieser Durchfall
äh ich würde gerne
Stuhl
und zu machen
Stuhlprobe? Ja Stuhlprobe
abnehmen, ja
aber sie nehmen auch noch Blutbild ab
Nierenwerte, Eberwerte
Ja, sehr wichtig
Was machen sie der therapeutisch?
Therapeutisch, äh
erst mal, Flistigkeit
Äh Infusion geben
und ähm
danach wenn äh Stuhlprobe
äh gibt es bestimmte Erreger
gegen, wenn dies gegen
diese Erreger ein Antibiotisch
ergibt äh
kann ich diese Medikamente verabreifen
und ähm
außerdem
ja
erst mal die Beide
ist genug, ich denke
Welche Erreger könnten das denn sein
oder einiges auszugeben gibt es
ähm
äh
noch ein Virus macht
über Kalendiere
und vielleicht Ekole
Ja, was gibt es noch?
äh was gibt es noch?
ähm wenn Blut gibt
Sanmonella, Shigella
aber er hat kein Blut gesehen
Man muss immer auch an Sanmonellen denken
ist wichtig
erst mal nicht so wichtig
sondern die müssen in Plüssigkeit geben
dass der wieder zu Kräften kommt
eine Infusionstherapie
und gegebenenfalls auch Schmerztherapie
wenn er starke Schmerzen hat
etwas Umfügkelkeit in den Durchfall geben
und dann muss man die Stuhlproben abwarten
wenn es eine Salmonellose ist
oder ein Neurovirus ist
kann man eh nicht viel machen
man könnte bei sehr schweren Verlauf
bei Salmonellen zum Beispiel
ein Antibiotikum geben
mit einem Neurovirus geht das nicht
haben wir nichts, ihr gibt es nichts
dann muss man wieder abwarten
aber was müssen die bei
Neurovirus machen
müssen sie den Patent isolieren
generell bei Brechdurchfall
im Krankenhaus
müssen sie den Patent isolieren, nicht vergessen
wenn sie den Verdacht haben
dass sie Neurovirus haben
immer isolieren
aber bei ihm ist das glaube ich eher
ein richtiger Brechdurchfall
das hat er nicht gesagt
sondern er hat nur 3 Mal erbrochen
aber dafür 15 Mal bei einem Toilette
wahrscheinlich ist einfach eine normale
Gastrinteritis
aber es kann auch eine Salmonellose sein
er hat gleich gegessen
er hat Kuchen gegessen
wo auch Eier mit drin sind, das weiß man nicht
genau
ja, sie haben es sehr gut gemacht
die Deutsch ist sehr gut
muss man sagen wirklich
also ich bin es Deutsch
dafür dass sie nur ein Jahr hier sind
also
sehr gut muss man sagen
auch die Analyse fand ich gut
Dankeschön
gibt es uns Fragen
war ja ein ganz einfacher Fall
eigentlich so schwer
der Fall nichts wirkliches
ist schwer, es war einfach eine normale
Gastrinteritis
mit Verdacht auf Salmonellose
bei
Salmonellen
als Antibiotika
Amoxicillin
ich bin mit nicht die Hauberische Antibiotika
ja, so pflurgische Lone
das kann man geben
oder man kann natürlich auch
Zerfahrersprung hinegeben
das macht man meistens
und man kann auch die
Anerobia
jedenfalls mit jeder Zoll
behandeln werden, welche da sein sollen
gibt es irgendwelche Fragen
wenn nicht
dann
wünsche ich einen schönen Sonntag
für ihn